hello and welcome to the fourth lesson
in native language in traduction to
historical linguistics and language
change last time around we looked at
some basic words in three latina core
Romance languages and determined how
they were related to each other
we also filled out their family tree
back in time and saw that they had this
relationship dependent on the existence
of some common ancestor that was an
actual language spoken in the past we
also determined that if we didn't have a
tested data for that language we'd have
to go back and reconstruct the language
to know what it was like in this lesson
we're going to do some of those basic
reconstructions to determine the shape
of an ancestral language that isn't
attested in other words we have no
written records of it we're going to
start with some fresh data from a few
new languages these are all Polynesian
languages I'll start out by saying
they're all related to each other we're
not trying to determine here if they're
related but rather what is the common
ancestral form that these cognates all
share these cognates all come from some
one word in the past what was the shape
of that one word so here are some words
for numbers in these languages as you
can see the forms are all very close
it's easy to tell based on this data at
least that the languages are related
I've given you the IPA forms the
international phonetic alphabet forms of
these words because we need to look at
sounds and sound change to determine how
these words changed if you're not
familiar with the IPA even though the
symbols used here are fairly basic I
have a whole lesson on that I'll put a
link to it below I also need to
introduce you to innovations and
retention innovations are changes to
ancestral forms that were introduced at
some point in the past they may occur in
one language or they may be shared by a
group of more closely related languages
retentions are those forms in this case
the sounds that go back to the common
ancestor what we need to do is determine
which of the sounds here are retentions
and which are innovations once we can do
that we can pause it common forms that
must have occurred in the parent or the
reconstructed language one simple
innovation shows up pretty quickly as we
look at this data notice that Hawaiian
always has this prefixed material this a
in front of every single number this
shows up only in Hawaiian and not in any
of the other languages we have good
grounds for assuming that this is an
innovation we don't have hard proof here
but the common material to all of these
numbers does not include that a so when
we're looking at the Hawaiian numbers
the common material is everything after
that a so let's compare individual
sounds notice the phoneme T the
voiceless dental glow civ that shows up
in most languages but also notice this
curiosity that some languages instead of
having the phoneme T have this voiceless
velar stop instead of the voiceless
dental stop in this case there's almost
something like a democratic vote by the
languages against the velar plosive the
K sound being the original phoneme we
have a pretty good indication that T was
an original phoneme a retention that
changed to the innovation K in a
specific language in Hawaiian so we
choose T as the ancestral inherited
retained phoneme in all of these
languages that then change to a k in
some instances but it would be lazy of
us to stop there we should go and
confirm against further data what we'd
find is that this is indeed the case
where there's a k in Hawaiian other
cognates and other languages have a T
and vice versa where there's a T in the
other languages there's a K in Hawaiian
so this seems to be confirmed across the
board we can posit some T in the
ancestral language what's more we're not
surprised to find that the number seven
has a form with T and not with a K in
that ancestral language so our
reconstruction of that root
pretty straightforward the question
becomes a bit more complicated when we
look at ELLs and ours take a look at the
word for the number two and for the
number three and the number eight in the
Polynesian languages that we have here
should the reconstructions of these
languages have an L or an R one thing to
notice here is that languages that have
an L seem to always have an L and
languages that have an R seem to always
have an R and there's a good
distribution here so which one should we
choose as I mentioned this isn't so
straightforward
what we'll need to do is to extend our
comparison to other languages these
languages aren't as closely related
they'll give us some comparative
evidence for the distribution of ELLs
and ours throughout the whole family you
can see in these languages that l and r
are distinct phonemes in other words L
doesn't always show up when R does
what's even more important is that these
languages are consistent in their
distribution of Ln R so it's reasonable
to suppose that this distinction was
also made in the common ancestor
language that's the parent of the
Polynesian languages were evaluating
based on this evidence will reconstruct
the numbers 2 & 3 this way we can then
conclude that some of the daughter
languages changed all instances of ELLs
and ours to R and other daughter
and ours to L when it comes to sound
change there's a lot going on there are
reasons for seeing typological
characteristics in other words these
types of sound changes tend to happen
these other ones don't or are less
common so we have grounds for saying
that the change from the phoneme f to
the phoneme h is a common and expected
one but we wouldn't expect h to turn
into f and the same goes for V and W we
commonly expect a would to turn into a V
like sound on top of that there are
regular types of sound changes that
happen in lane
and these are especially important for
understanding language change if you'd
like to take a look at those types of
regular sound changes like assimilation
which I believe I've mentioned before in
a previous lesson to get a more in-depth
understanding of assimilation
dissimulation things like metathesis
compensatory lengthening and so on I put
together a brief page with definitions
and examples I'll leave you the URL for
that page as well I really hope this
lessons been helpful for you I know it's
a brief introduction but take a look at
the site you'll get more information
there and a couple of exercises as well
thanks for learning with me
you